Nos piden resolver para "x" y nos dan la ecuación,
raíz cuadrada de "5x" cuadrada menos 8 es igual a 2x,
ya tenemos la expresión con el radical de un lado...
del lado izquierdo,
y lo más fácil ahora es
elevar al cuadrado ambos lados de la ecuación,
elevamos al cuadrado entonces el lado izquierdo y elevamos al cuadrado el lado derecho,
¿aquí qué tenemos?
Si tenemos el cuadrado de la raíz cuadrada d
e "5x" cuadrada menos 8...
esto es directamente ,
5x cuadrada menos 8...
que es igual a
"2x" elevado al cuadrado es
2 al cuadrado por "x" al cuadrado
que es "4x" cuadrada,
ya tenemos aquí una ecuación cuadrática.
Vamos a simplificar la aún más para resolverla,
vamos a pasar las "x" cuadradas de un solo lado,
restemos "4x" cuadrada a ambos lados,
o no...
vamos mejor a restar "-5x" cuadrada
para facilitarnos las cosas
préstamos "-5x" cuadrada del lado izquierdo
y restamos "-5x" cuadrada del lado derecho.
¿Qué nos resulta entonces?
"5x" cuadrada con "-5x" cuadrada se cancelan,
por eso estamos haciendo esto,
nos queda -8 que es igual a
"4x" cuadrada menos 5x cuadrada
es "-1x" cuadrada o
simplemente "-x" cuadrada.
¿Ahora qué hacemos?
Bien, vamos a multiplicar por -1 ambos lados de la ecuación
para que se cancelen los signos menos,
o podríamos dividir entre -1,
que es exactamente lo mismo,
entonces multiplicamos por -1 el lado izquierdo
y multiplicamos por -1 el lado derecho,
el lado izquierdo nos resulta 8
y del lado derecho es "x" cuadrada.
Ahora, vamos a tomar raíz cuadrada
a ambos lados de la ecuación,
nos queda raíz cuadrada de "x" cuadrada,
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 8
estamos tomando la raíz cuadrada principal
a ambos lados de la ecuación,
del lado derecho nos queda "x",
y del lado izquierdo vamos a sacar la raíz cuadrada de 8,
vamos a escribir 8 como,
2 por 4 ,así es que vamos a tener aquí
la raíz cuadrada, de 2 por 4,
lo cual podemos escribir como la raíz cuadrada de 2,
por la raíz cuadrada de 4...
mmm...no me gusta este verde...
Esto sigue siendo igual a "x",
bien, sabemos que la raíz cuadrada
de 4 es igual a 2,
por lo que ahora tenemos,
2,
este término lo estoy poniendo por delante,
2 por raíz de 2,
esto es igual a "x".
Vamos a verificar ahora,
que ésta es la solución de la ecuación original.
Sustituyamos "x" en el lado izquierdo de la ecuación,
el lado izquierdo nos resulta en 5,
que multiplica a,
"x" al cuadrado,
"x" que es 2 raíz de 2 elevado al cuadrado,
menos 8 y a eso le saco la raíz cuadrada,
me estoy enfocando solo del lado izquierdo.
Esto resulta entonces en,
la raíz cuadrada de 5 que multiplica a
2 al cuadrado es igual a 4
y esto que multiplica a
raíz de 2 al cuadrado que es 2,
y a esto le restamos menos 8
y ahora tenemos 5 por 4 = 20
por 2 = 40,
menos 8, 32
esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 32...
la raíz cuadrada 32
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 16 por 2,
la raíz cuadrada de 16 es 4,
así que esto sería la raíz cuadrada de 16,
por la raíz cuadrada de 2 ó 4 por raíz cuadrada de 2,
eso lo que obtenemos cuando sustituimos el valor de "x" en el lado izquierdo de la ecuación,
recuerda que la ecuación original
no estaba elevada al cuadrado,
solo era la parte en verde,
la raíz de "5x" cuadrada menos 8.
Veamos cuál es el valor de 2x
originalmente lado derecho es 2x,
elevamos al cuadrado posteriormente para resolver la ecuación
¿a cuánto equivale entonces "2x"?
2x equivale a 2 por 2 raíz de 2,
y esto es igual a 2 por 2 = 4 raíz de 2,
y ya habíamos visto que cuando "x" es igual a 2 raíz de 2, el lado izquierdo también es 4 raíz de 2
acuérdate que cuando empezamos
el lado izquierdo se veía como esto,
no tenía los cuadrados...
no habíamos elevado al cuadrado,
borramos esto
y así era como estaba originalmente la ecuación,
cuando sustituimos esto el lado izquierdo obtuvimos 4 raíz de 2 y cuando lo sustituimos del lado derecho
también obtuvimos 4 raíz de 2,
así es que definitivamente...
esto estaba en negro....
definitivamente esta es la solución de la ecuación.